- Let's compare the number
0.7 to the number 0.09.
And there's a bunch of ways to do this,
but the way that I'm going to tackle it is
I'm gonna start looking
at each of the digits,
starting with the leftmost digit.
And so we can start right over here
in the ones place.
You always want to compare ones place
to ones place, so for example
if we compare these two numbers,
they both have zero ones.
So the ones place doesn't tell us much.
So now let's go one
place value to the right.
Let's go to the tenths place.
This number has seven tenths,
while this number has zero tenths.
That by itself tells us that
this is the larger number.
We would put an inequality
symbol right over here.
We wanna open it up to the larger number,
where it points to the smaller number.
So this says 0.7 is greater than 0.09.
Now you might be tempted
to say oh wait, wait.
Look, but if we went one
more digit to the right
you have nine hundredths here,
and you have no hundredths over here.
We could write a zero over here,
and you'd say well look,
you have no hundredths over here.
But the nine hundredths don't matter.
Remember, even if you had 10 hundredths,
that's the same thing as one tenth.
So it doesn't matter that nine is somehow
greater than seven.
What matters is it's in
a place to the right.
Even if you increased by
another hundredth here
you'd only get to one tenth.
This thing over here has seven tenths.
Let's do another one of these.
Let's say we wanted to compare,
let's say we wanted to compare
0.29,
let's say I wanna compare that
to 0.31.
Now this one you might say is a little bit
more straightforward, depending on how
you think about it.
If you say hey, this is 29 hundredths,
this is 31 hundredths,
we have more hundredths
on the right-hand side.
So let me open my inequality
to the larger value
and I would say 0.29, or 29 hundredths
is less than 31 hundredths.
Another way you could have done this
is you could have looked
in the ones place,
say okay, they both have zero ones,
but then you look in the tenths place,
say this only has two tenths,
while this has three tenths.
I shouldn't have to keep looking
at the digits to the right of that.
I can just compare this two tenths
to the three tenths.
Three tenths is larger, and so I would say
that 29 hundredths is
less than 31 hundredths.
Let's do one more, just for fun.
Let's compare, let's compare
0.6 to, I'll do them in the same color.
0.06.
Which of these is the larger number?
Well we do the same thing
that we've been doing.
You can first go to the ones place.
Say okay, this has no
ones, this has no ones.
Okay that doesn't tell us much.
Then the tenths place.
This has six tenths, this has zero tenths.
So this number is going to be larger.
It has more tenths.
It doesn't matter who has more hundredths.
Hundredths are much smaller than tenths.
They're a tenth of the size of a tenth.
So this has six tenths,
this has zero tenths.
So this number is larger.
0.6 is greater than 0.06.
It's actually ten times greater
but we can talk about
that in other videos.